every Thursday Linda Chris Tonti
demonstrates with opponents of the
former Suharto regime she was also
involved in protests at the end of the
90s that brought down the military
dictatorship many dissidents disappeared
without trace a poem against forgetting
family tlacolula this weapon terrible
sorry Anupam appear on the coast because
Dinaric was a con man drago t-cells fell
apart upon younger figure Tatanka bibi's
happened in the 90s she was part of an
underground movement the risks were high
today Indonesia has a democratically
elected president but there is little
will to address the past or bring those
responsible for crimes to justice the
fight for freedom of expression goes on
I need a lot of freedom because I'm a
political person in my writings
if the Indonesian army or whatever Army
Special Force kidnapped me if they kill
me I will not be sad because I don't
have children I don't have husband I
don't have anything
although Linda Christin T's writing has
been described as magic realism the
subject matter is always political if
you want to change something in the
society you have to be brief to the
deaths maybe you are not alone maybe in
the world there are some people like you
maybe they live in the worst situations
more than me and because of that I never
feel alone
you